some people think that intelligence is
the crowning achievement of evolution
well if that's true there should be more
intelligent creatures on the planet
Earth but in the best of our knowledge
were the only ones the dinosaurs around
the earth for roughly 200 million years
and the best of our knowledge not a
single dinosaur became intelligent we
humans modern humans have been on the
earth for roughly a hundred thousand
years only a tiny fraction of the 4.5
billion years that the earth has been
around so you come to the rather
astounding conclusion that intelligence
is not really necessary that mother
Nature has done perfectly well with non
intelligent creatures for millions of
years and that we as intelligent
creatures are the new kid on the block
and so then you begin to wonder how did
we become intelligent what separated us
from the animals well there are
basically three ingredients at least
three that help to propel us to become
intelligent one is the opposable thumb
you need a tentacle a claw an opposable
thumb in order to manipulate the
environment so that's one of the
ingredients of intelligence to be able
to change the world around you second is
eyesight but the eyesight of a predator
we have eyes to the front of our face
not to the side of our face and Hawaii
animals with eyes at the front of their
face are predators lions tigers and
foxes animals with eyes the side of the
face are prey and they are not as
intelligent like a rabbit we say dumb
bunny and smart as a fox and there's a
reason for that because the Fox is a
predator it has to learn how to ambush
it has to learn how to have stealth
camouflage it has to psych out the enemy
and anticipate the motion of the enemy
that is its prey if you are dumb bunny
all you have to do is run and the third
basic ingredient is language because you
have to be able to communicate your
knowledge to the
next generation and to the best of our
knowledge animals do not communicate
knowledge to their offspring other than
by simply communicating certain
primitive emotions there's no book
there's no language there's no culture
but which animals can communicate their
knowledge to the next generation and so
we think that's how the brain evolved we
have an opposable thumb we have a
language of maybe five to ten thousand
words and we have eyesight that is
stereo eyesight the eyesight of a
predator and predators tame seem to be
smarter than prey and then you ask
another question how many animals on the
earth satisfy these three basic
ingredients and then you come to the
astounding conclusion the answer is
almost none so perhaps there's a reason
why we became intelligent and the other
animals did not they did not have the
basic ingredients that would one day
propel us to become intelligent then the
next question asked in Planet of the
Apes and asking any number of science
fiction movies is can you accentuate
intelligence can you take an ape and
make the ape intelligent well believe it
or not the answer could be yes we are
98.5 percent genetically equivalent to a
chimpanzee only a handful of genes
separate us from the chimps and yet we
live twice as long and we have thousands
of words in our vocabulary
simcha had maybe just a few hundred and
we've isolated many of those genes that
separate us from the chimpanzees for
example the ASP gene governs the size of
the crane cranial capacity so that by
monkeying with just one gene you can
literally double the size of the brain
case and the brain itself and so in the
future not today but in the future we
may use gene therapy to begin the
process of making perhaps a chimpanzee
intelligent we know the genes that will
increase the size of the brain we've
isolated now the gene
you manual dexterity by which you can
make tools we have found the genes which
give you the ability to articulate
thousands of words and so it may be
possible to tinker with the genome of a
chimpanzee so that they have a larger
brain case they have better manual
dexterity and they have the ability to
articulate a larger vocabulary but then
what do you get you get a primate that
looks very similar to a human and so my
personal attitude is why bother we
already have humans just look outside
the door so why bother the manipulator a
chimpanzee because as you make a
chimpanzee more and more intelligent it
becomes more and more human-like with a
vocabulary with vocal chords with manual
dexterity with a larger brain case and a
spine to support a larger brain case
that's called a human